to peter parker protecting the glass
black dahlia necklace he buys in venice
during his european school trip is
almost as important as saving the world
in spider-man far from home at the start
of the trip he has a detailed plan about
how to tell his crush mj how he feels
about her and it all hinges on giving
her the necklace unfortunately for peter
while he saves the world he doesn't save
the necklace somewhere between peter
giving it to happy for safe keeping and
stopping mysterio's reckless plot the
necklace gets broken luckily for peter
mj says she likes it better that way and
kisses him the necklace becomes the
symbol of how much peter and mj care for
each other but what becomes of it by the
time spider-man no way home comes to an
end well the film picks up right where
the far-from-home mid-credit scene
leaves off with peter and mj in a
crowded intersection at the exact moment
that j jonah jameson reveals peter's
identity as spider-man to the world
chaos ensues with people suddenly
crowding around them forcing peter to
get mj and himself to safety in that
scene she's also wearing the broken
necklace in spite of a far-from-home
mid-credits scene suggesting otherwise
if you look carefully you'll notice a
continuity error between the mid-credits
scene in spider-man far from home and
the opening of spider-man no way home in
the former mj is not wearing her
necklace but in the latter she is only a
few seconds passed between the two
scenes so it seems like this was merely
a mistake but who knows
maybe mj simply didn't want her necklace
to snag on peter's spidey suits while
they were swinging around so she took it
off and then put it back on after he set
her down she does also have it around
her neck after the plane ride back to
new york the necklace is clearly an
important part of mj's costume now
considering that zendaya also wears it
in the no way home title announcement
video additionally mj is still wearing
it at the end of spider-man no way home
even though she's entirely forgotten
peter parker by that point the latter
detail also forces us to ask who does mj
think gave her the necklace if she
doesn't remember peter spider-man she
did of course figure out spidey's
identity once already and it's entirely
possible she'll do it again especially
if she knows she has a connection to him
through the necklace
interestingly there is also a marvel
comics girl gang called the black
dahlias who act as vigilantes most
likely mj will go to mit and be
successful there but there is always a
chance a future mcu film could see her
start her own vigilante group if she
does the odds are high that she'll
likely only find herself caught in
spider-man's web once more the fact that
the black dahlia necklace is important
enough to mj's character that having her
wear it in the film's opening created a
continuity error suggests that it may
carry some significance beyond just
symbolizing peter's affection at least
one reddit user is in agreement
proposing the necklace will be key to
her story in a future spider-man film
one user started a thread on the no way
home subreddit suggesting that the
necklace will prompt not just mj but ned
as well to remember their former
friendship with peter
since no way home possibly sets up that
ned will learn to wield magic in the
same manner as doctor strange they
theorize that the necklace will spur mj
to approach ned about casting a spell to
help the two of them regain their
memories of peter in response another
user called this theory a really good
idea and wrote that it would give them
more agency in the story compared to
their prior appearances in which their
roles are largely defined by supporting
spider-man whether the necklace inspires
mj to start a vigilante group or
encourages ned to learn a spell that can
bring back lost memories there's a
decent chance a necklace will remain an
important part of spider-man lore as the
franchise continues
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
spider-man no way home are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]